o lado pessoal que quem fala é o dark e
vejam só a música nova
não estamos aqui para julgar mas está um
jogo de terror pessoal parem a vossa
cueca já sabem ou já consumo a banda
sonora de junho espero só ou não possuir
melhor de cinco já vem virando estamos
na casa de banho mais detrimento da dor
e do sempre olha só sinto me atormentava
a microsoft a brincadeira não estou
muito bem presente o inter é só para
insurgente siraj com o espelho a
eslováquia irá que substituirá henrique
eu não estava esperando isso não foi uma
chapa fica porque para já temos uma
chave que provavelmente é por esta porta
vamos lá abrirá os debates em roma que
já começa a e paredes todas fundidas é é
caso do doutor olha aí olha aí o
ministério está investigando o escondo o
foco fazem filmes podem contratar isso
button é eu tirei um curso de inglês em
frança eu sabem também às vezes falar só
quer nenhum europeu
eu não sei do confuso estamos num
[ __ ] senhora você estava em não ter
essa pra você não vamos sair daqui não
olha só será que vamos resolver um
instante funciona mesmo opções e nem
estranho é o som do bicho e vamos
avançar pegará já se aproxima de que
alguma coisa se importava não esta
quebra é quente o pânico foto ou és
abril feito por franco suíço e agora 111
bracinho mas esta cortina para se casar
com manuel luís goucha esta portava em
de turnover que é a retirar esta [ __ ]
que é preciso uma chave de fendas que
elas ficarão presos até então vamos em
busca da shalom beijo mais quatro
magníficos tem uma natureza é anos que
começou a ficar mais explica sam
funciona a já possui 30 cineastas assim
né
não é assim que funciona como é que
falta a esta aqui ó
sou grande decifrador de enigmas será
que abril teve qualquer coisa que alguma
coisa ruim sida eo êxito é o [ __ ] não
precisa tarde faz não quero aqui dizer
carvalho não está ninguém bom já tem um
código todo florido aqui na parede
achei que a gente já sai por aí já sair
também
um dois três quatro cinco seis e sete de
ataque o código a cair esta coisa
funciona a f-future me senti em sanaa ao
tempo achava que falta agora o caminho
shopping
agora tem que por aqui o código zinho
não é boa
musicalmente as interrompido porque não
sai nesta 3a canadá japão e 35 e agora
dois ou seguir nenhum susto não né
será que estes garotos têm qualquer
coisa parece que sim para cada 2 horas
ao xixi e tem uma outra mensagem a
frente terá que devolver envolver 100
dessa escola 70 flui a morte vai
libertar o fire sofri isso é propor na
máquina ou acima já sai daqui preparado
pra segundona está correto quando voltou
ao mesmo sítio é esse um susto nesta
coisa né e épico gritar assim não sou
galileu a cabeça nas eleita é cabeça do
homem lá embaixo é isso o supostamente
tem que lavar outra vez não sou o
salvador funciona mas não não isso é uma
armadilha é uma armadilha isso vou ficar
sob vamos estar aqui nessa rápida pode
rápido e vai embora não acontece nada a
falar só um sustinho não eu nem vi
aquela porta 8 e desloca a katusha agora
supostamente com este disco gravado por
cima assim macau musiquinha [ __ ]
agora é difícil andar por aí já há algum
amiguinho a cabeça dele está aqui uma
faca em dueto remover é isso mesmo
meu deus consegui abrir a porta um
quarto secreto comprei partida boa
discreta esta coisa ou uma caixa um
código preciso deixar isso em qualquer
lugar não é tua amiguinho para lá é a
minha postura não gosto de dar dinheiro
ao filho
o game over retrai canal já com singh já
começou assim o botafogo não dá não
funciona
com física para o assunto embora não a
obra em portugal mas o que eu preciso
alguma coisa o transmita uma faca
enquanto futebol é injusto que se
explicar alguma coisa isso aqui hoje
o que o faz na nenê volta porém volta
redonda
quem não quer que isso vou roubar a faca
mas estou a morrer pelos usuários
ae foi morto
tem alguma coisa a cada vez que uma faca
ela vinha e agora é só cá a uma tumba
que está sem cabeça negócio era dia de
viva com muita calma e isso mata mata
mata mata mas o flamengo foi muito
estranho supostamente a suposta briga
não é com o plano de agora já tenho uma
faca e sharon tate efe io/rr foi o inter
aí vou traduzir o lajense espero que não
tenha esquecido de sexta-feira netos
alves que foi o resto eu quero que eu
saí com o botafogo que eu já não sei que
estamos a falar aqui mas tem que ir pra
festa agora brinca bota o fado luís
kitamba não vai beber mesmo foi no
escuro então foi de 76 então masters e
não seria importante não só pela cmf
mais sete mas sem matar ninguém isto é
invencível sobre eles dois mais forte do
que jesus vamos entrar num valor símbolo
para iludir o eleitor que não funcionou
nada até que um código está em alguma
forma de um tiro que nos quanto a esses
[ __ ] esperando 19 e manhã
é uma chave
quem conseguiu escapar acha que eu vou
forró dos plays só vou ficar porque com
espírito é também o estado é para que
vocês tenham curtido aqui no jogo do my
friends do maylasky fraga dem é tá
sabendo que você acha que favorito fique
bem e até aproximar